last night the president-elect unveiled
a plan to spend nearly two
trillion dollars on new programs to roll
back the economic damage from the
pandemic
wishehang is covering the biden
transition in wilmington delaware rija
good morning
good morning anthony and good morning to
everybody president-elect biden is
urging lawmakers
to pass this package fast calling it a
moral obligation but speed
may be a challenge not only does he have
to convince
many republicans to get on board with
that huge price tag
but senators will likely be in the
middle of president trump's second
impeachment trial and confirmation
hearings for mr biden's cabinet nominees
the president-elect says they should
split up their work day so they can
do it all we must act now and act
decisively
president-elect joe biden's plan to
rescue a ravaged economy
would offer direct relief by sending
fourteen hundred dollar stimulus
checks extending and increasing
unemployment
insurance from three hundred to four
hundred dollars a week
and providing a higher child tax credit
the crisis of deep human suffering is in
plain sight
and there's no time to waste the
thursday night speech
also served as mr biden's first formal
sales pitch to lawmakers
especially republicans who will likely
bulk at the nearly two
trillion dollar price tag i know what i
just described does not come cheaply
but failure to do so will cost us dearly
the proposal also includes 440 billion
dollars for helping communities and
small
businesses and aims to bump up the
minimum wage to 15
an hour mr biden unveiled details on the
same day the labor department announced
nearly 1 million people filed for
unemployment the first week of this
month
up by around 23 percent from the week
before
they were in the middle of the once in
several generations economic crisis
he said the economic spiral is linked to
the pandemic
calling for 400 billion dollars to deal
with coven 19
including more money for testing
assisting schools
and vaccinations the vaccine rollout in
the united states has been a dismal
failure thus far
today mr biden plans to unveil how his
administration will roll out the vaccine
promising they will deliver 100 million
shots in the first 100 days
of his presidency back in washington
crews are getting the white house ready
for a new
first family they spent thursday
clearing it out hauling out
several boxes traditionally the bidens
would move in on inauguration day but
this year
they won't do that until crews have a
chance to give the white house a
deep cleaning and disinfection tony
all right we just thank you very much